on your list of dream roles where does
wonder woman rank i've always wanted to
be a superhero and i feel like wonder
woman is the ultimate superhero so
pretty high
i could see you being a superhero before
all is said and done well our wonder
woman week continues with rachel smith
in nashville and
gal gadot is taking on kristen wiig
yes and it is amazing guys who knew this
funny lady could be
so fierce and gal gave us the story
behind the scenes
[Music]
we won't be doing that today the first
action sequence that you see in the
movie
we took over um an abandoned
mall from the 80s and we completely
dressed it up
like the 80s
and then the entire ceiling was covered
with
wire rigs everything that you see there
is either me or my stunt girls
you have quite the showdowns with miss
kristen wig
we would do the fight and we fight and
we go all the way and then they say
cut and then we're like oh my god are
you okay did i hurt you then we hug
and we're like it was fun it's crazy
any of your little amazons did they come
to set and watch
mama uh my girls we were shooting on
locations
they were always there it's they're part
of the
circus you know we can do it by
ourselves it takes a village
what is like a teaching a sentiment
wisdom that you hope
you're able to instill within your own
children
that there's no shortcuts and there's no
easy ways sometimes i i see
you know kids or teenagers that all they
want to do is to be famous
but that's really like it's it's
nonsense
you just gotta work hard that's there's
no secrets
gals bff kristen agrees the new mom's
twins with fiance avi rothman were
delivered earlier this year
via surrogate the couple kept the news a
secret at first
now that i have kids it's like oh i
don't want this to be
about me i don't want to think about me
anymore and just having these like
two other little beings that i get to
take care of
is like so amazing i feel more relaxed
in a way
really yeah i mean right now because
they're in there
and our wonder woman week continues
tomorrow what made kristin
totally fan girl out on set it is a
great story you gotta hear guys